topic is going to be about yeah good
transition you about it let's just go
right to it if you don't about let just
wild Super Chat let's just jump right
into it cuz gas does set it up so this
is the hot one man this is this is the
hot one right here shout out to uh good
friend to the real Tom hon also um Nate
the hate uh lot of talk going on right
now about Xbox
exclusives and
uh C sign that's what I was going to
start with but um look there's a Rover
you know that um and Xbox highly
critically acclaimed Xbox first part it
got worse during the show jez actually
posted something oh what je said let's
get it let's get posted an article that
was pretty much like Microsoft is
considering releasing uh let's go let's
go freak it up bring it up I'll read the
you read that one rum suggest M bringing
more games to Nintendo switch and
Playstation but what's the truth and
he's oh okay it's it's an editorial it's
editorial okay got you got you got so
yeah so pretty much you know he saying
he's pretty much ing Microsoft in the
back or entertain the idea of buring
some of their back lock to other
platforms I've also had the same thing
which is why I got a lot of hate and I
you know you know what I I I want the
future to be Gaz you were wrong here's
some Crow eat it and I I would gladly
eat it I said I was wrong I was wrong
beat the crap please please beat the
crap out of me I deserve to beat beat
them beat me to a for please being wrong
I want to be so wrong I say I'm wrong
I'm hearing it from very reputable s and
I know everyone says irreputable s but
if I say more I get them in trouble lose
their jobs these people I trust and
again it's speculative because we don't
know like the even he says like or she
says
um even got nervous there the don't blow
up the sauce
gas uh they saying like look you never
know things could change but things are
quite Advanced on some of these things
and I'm just like
look I know satin Adella had to take a
little hit on his bonus and then you
have to convince the shareholders and
Game Pass Subs at the plateaued and
whatnot but you went in with $70 billion
what was your plan like you do you do
this you do it depends on what games
they are like would you would we really
care like I'm and it's not Dam you might
call it damage control but this is
something I person well do I give a damn
if SE your thieves or grounded was as
gas games appeared on Playstation I'm
like not really because that could
probably benefit the the the players
name is life service games right then
where do you draw the line Halo no don't
you dare
touchfield yeah that would be ridic
that's not
happening going out there going to we a
moving that over there exclusive for now
so I I I just want and I'm trying to
like jostle the community not to come at
me for saying this but come go at
Microsoft to say shut up if this rumors
is true and it maybe rumors or
speculation kill it kill it before they
even because we know Microsoft's
reactive to Fan feedback with the gold
price hike and everything with the
console really you need to tell them to
shut up Phil Spencer stop doing this I'm
not saying you're doing it Phil but stop
committing to this Kumbaya thing and he
himself said in 2020 I don't really love
this idea that for every one of our
games there comes this little rumor oh
it's going to end up on switch or not
but that's I feel we should set a better
expectation with our fans than that so
why are we having this conversation
today failed in that end it end it
definitively shouldn't be hard for you
to say look what I said before some
platforms where Game Pass exists that's
it don't worry guys we are all behind X
it doesn't hurt you for saying that so
we need that Xbox fans need that and if
XBox don't do it it's a slippery slope
and it it calls into just completely
it's the worst worst thing that Xbox
just give up at that point because I was
like we rally behind this brand because
we've been following it for decades and
we have this vision of what the brand
can do and you're essentially removing
yourself as a competitor some people
disagree with the idea of what
competition means here but I think you
being in the hardware space and you
having your exclusivity cement you as a
competitor and when you get this gray
area and some games are gray L dusk
Falls but it doesn't no one
cares big bigger deal but if you start
the slippery slope and it's just really
going to
undermine the the effort you put into it
the mass Market thinking oh it will come
to PlayStation eventually can't do that
man and you have to be clear what games
oh we're going to allow some games what
games how do we know which games you're
going to allow in the future have a
question mark yes it's all messaging
Ming let me let me ask you this gu so
like so so let's get to the elephant in
the room C to Tom hederson Right Nate
the game that people are concerned about
is high five Rush high five rush so so
how would you feel guys if you wake up
and we the new Nintendo Direct
happens and you see chai and 808 on the
new Nintendo switch coming this fall how
do you feel about
this do do you think uh what what about
the business aspect I mean you know it's
going to sell like hot cakes over
there need we I think it would we need
to understand the parameters and how
wide this goes if high-fi Rush goes to
Nintendo switch I personally wouldn't I
love highi High Rush the switch is just
and it runs in its own lane like what
differentiate switch from the you know
your mobile so you play a game pass on
that right it's not a game pass thing
but James Morrison says I'd have he have
nightmares he have nightmares he
definitely messed up in the game right
now but I personally don't think the
switch is a problem for me and you might
call me a console war oh but if we hear
that state of play new to the to do I
feel it new to nend PlayStation fans get
ready sh
bro be on my head the whole time your
timeline going to be
crazy canot happen canot happen no now
is this the emotionality of a of a
hardcore Xbox guy not looking at the bus
S as well it's a business call as well
because ultimately what you're doing is
you're diluting the value of the Xbox
which you've already done by making this
PC and everything stuff you canot kiss
Mo smileing like
do it it's a huge L and I will call it
out it depends on what games are coming
like grounded and okay pent like okay
pentan comes to
switch that oh okay you okay but don't
they get their grubby hairs off off chai
high five they can't have that they yeah
I mean that's a bit what oh hold the
line mustard heart talk mustard heart
talk we falling for a king hold all
right I got you I got you but we I got
to speak to my homies first though cuz
cuz G and kid are perfect for the show
for this reason they have been on the
front line saying they are tired of
having to ask this answer this question
about XBox exclusive will it will it it
be will it and now we got some reputable
sources King that that that are saying
potentially that this title that came
out as a stealth drop right that is
beloved could be flirting with the
[Music]
Enemy
man I got you hold on so so gas
absolutely under no circumstance it's
it's PlayStation that can't go on then
it's a problem cannot cannot do that
cannot do that cannot sleep in the eny
like that that's just crazy man right
all right kid I got to get you real
quick cuz kid you been on the front you
been on the front line since PC came
into the picture yeah and that and that
one hurt um and it's just PC um I'm know
I'm with G it's like you can't do that
especially after this Activision stuff
when they will sabotage that deal when
they still trying to sabotage the deal
after you've done signed an agreement
with them like my thing is is that I
even Nintendo it's like all right
whatever like I'm with G with like
Nintendo I don't look at it as like it's
like all right whatever when they got
aie cuphead yeah there's a precedent aie
and Willow with both of them and the SE
is over there yeah they already got so
it's like go ahead send bed The Edge
over there like I
don't s some old stuff don't you be
sending the new the new hotness okay
like heck actually hellblade didn't get
ported to switch until after Microsoft
bought him by the way hellblade got to
switch on like 20121 maybe um so it's
like the switch yeah I don't care I I do
wish there was some give and take though
does Nintendo and Microsoft have a
relationship like they both
collaborated yeah but they got to be
like give us that bayetta give us that
uh the with Astro chain give us
something throw us a bone brother love
show me some love brother love
see like a one-sided relationship to you
that's what you say they keep getting
all our stuff that but the minute you
bring PlayStation into it it starts to
become problematic because the thing is
is that show some like Xbox is already
devalued right because of like the PC
and cloud gaming they keep talking all
this nonsense stuff and then you have to
start to worry it's like all right what
is the point for the platform to console
like I'm a dieh hard console gamer but
the console I choose to play on is Xbox
and if you start taking away the weapons
or the reason why I play on it what is
your plan if you either all in or you
you're all out and I just yeah like I I
proposed in my video today that I um put
out it's like yo go if if you going to
do this then go the way of these mobile
PCS allow all these manufacturers to
make Xboxes and then you just put out
the software that a bunch of Xbox stop
playing oh yeah like you know what I
mean it's like I it's it's a weird
scenario it's like and I want them and
this sounds horrible but I want them to
Value the Xbox
Fanboy EOS system I mean I don't even
think it's the fan I think it's the E
the PlayStation Fanboys until they can't
afford it I mean that it's it's
happening but the thing is like at some
point they got to Value the Xbox Fanboy
like you got to value that fandom I
don't want no Merk or no T-shirt I want
an exclusive like I want a reason to
like prop up like the Xbox console and
you get into Muddy Waters and it does
we're in we're in the area of social
media and I feel like honestly console
gaming the market is the console Wars
and Fanboys I feel like they're
dictating what people should buy in the
stores because people underestimate how
popular social media is the Twitter and
YouTube and and the talking points
regarding Xbox compared to PlayStation
is like by PlayStation it's become apped
um and I do think there's still time for
I feel like Microsoft is at a time and
Xbox is at a time where they literally
are in position to do what PlayStation
has done itone right at the C ABK just
got like why I do this now right you got
was it the
glove infity guard just go snap your
dang on finger snap the finger erase
them from existence stop playing give it
all the way if you could literally just
have give yourself five years just to do
what they did to you so like I no more
y'all snaap them out of existence snaap
them out of just give them a taste and
right right when they're on the brink of
bankruptcy then give them all the G like
wait
wait y kid that was
cold like don't do it right now do it
right now don't give him a chance to
breathe finish
them like I feel you you speaking for
the heart brother you
speaking adct you up man where you at
with this
bro ah I feel like they just them
stepping on rkes again and you know the
fact that hearing this from multiple
sources I I think it's it's happening I
don't know what to degree here's the
thing though people sit there they go
out there and they say you know
Microsoft can't
announce uh any game without the
exclusivity being in question stuff like
blade it's like they they're their own
the self to blame for that it's like the
reason people are very open with
PlayStation when PlayStation does it
it's cuz PlayStation is very clear for
the most part yeah that's ours yeah that
that's ours Xbox is like that's ours for
now there's no question when it comes we
switch it or like you know because it's
like I said when they first bought
Bethesda and and Phil was clear that we
bought one of the reasons we bought this
is for Val you on our console Market
when Activision was first bought I saw
people like Paris be like it's not even
a question these are
exclusive because Phil came out there
and he said this is ours right and then
within a day Phils like but kind of like
and and then the blade we're gonna put
this out on the stage but we won't put
our name on it like it's just like why
this is the only Xbox that happened too
at this point it's just like just go
through third party or don't go third
party like stop it stop playing like
like and people are like oh you know
what what's help no okay Mo been waiting
for this day he TI y waking up to I
thought it was gonna be ay because aie I
thought in my mind maybe moon has worked
some kind of some kind of arrangement
with Xbox and got the the the IP of ory
because they kind of did something
similar with with Alan Wake when it come
to remedy games so I was like maybe
Microsoft's doing more of a a backend
seat where they're like if these IPS and
we can't do nothing with them and their
developers aren't going to work on them
and they want them let's just sell it to
them and get some some money out of this
so I thought okay maybe that's what it
is and Moon Studios has published that
game on uh on PlayStation and then
people like high five rush you mean to
tell me that one of the most successful
games they've had in years they're like
that's not ours finally a banger yeah
that that's not ours it's just it's just
crazy man cuz it's just like high-fi
rush and any other year would have been
a gaming the air Contender factual
factual last year was a phenomenal that
that that those years don't happen often
that's and it's just like it's crazy
because like you you look at it from
that standpoint it's just like why at
this point if they buy anything you know
open at everything like it's just it's
frustrating because Xbox will have I I
don't watch basketball like an oloop or
what yeah they get the alley right there
right there get the alleyoop and instead
of instead of doing it they're like I'm
going to pass it to the person behind me
and then he trips and does five
somersaults and the ball goes up and
then and the PlayStation dude grabs it
like it's just like come
on K is tight with us he's so Furious he
about to go in on us I continue first I
got you K there needs to be and I know
what he's going to say hold the line
some great
a lot of must heart talking don't like
this talk that's fine you know who you
need to aim that that attack towards
King Microsoft for they crummy ass
messaging language language if Microsoft
would be clear on how they handle
situations and business don't try to
duck these shots now if they would be
clear on how they handle stuff there
would be no conversations we know we
know what would be going on now I can
see the Call of Duty thing being you
know the Activision thing okay you know
that's legal they barely got that we we
had to make we had to make some
arrangements but but when it comes to
like high-fi rush we can argue the
high-fi rush is probably the the closest
thing they've had to a game of the year
Contender besides Starfield in years
factual and it's like oh we got this and
it's like they they got a they got that
like they got the golden ticket for wlly
Wonka and they're like let me bring
corporate car here for a quick second
though um so what about this
I know you hate I know you hate him I
but we got we got to let him talk some
sometimes so the question he going say
is all right now I hear y'all right but
we don't crank the numbers and this
high- five Rush is a perfect fit for the
Nintendo like they crank the numbers
that the Xbox one was going to do well
at the gate like they cranked the
numbers that the connect was going to
over to the market like they cranked the
numbers like mixer was going to do
phenomenal Corp Co finish he just want
to ask a question so the question is now
we did the mat right and they about to
jump out with a new cons new console and
we know they will buy this thing hand on
and we we we may have made a
miscalculation by making that a stealth
drop you know what I'm saying we ain't
get that retail like we and now we get
that on the back end plus some just for
existing and you know we friends with
them we we cool with we're bows in the
game you know what I'm saying it's only
a matter of time this could be one of
the things to get
us the the trade is all right we going
to get G pass over there this this is
part of negotiations this the remember
Bowser said he liked the relationship
remember when the dirt came out
when Rel when the dirt came out Phil
said yeah we would have bought
him everybody thought it was going to go
left and like no we're still cool with
those guys we're still I feel them on
that but you can say the same concept
over there at PlayStation when Ratchet
and Clank was barely making profit if
made profit it could have EAS to be like
they make no profet just read they
didn't make we're going to let it go
everywhere that ocean over there we
wanted over there that ocean we wanted
over there but they didn't they're like
we made our we we made our stances we we
understood release dates and we're going
to we're going to we're going to hold
that and Xbox like high five rushed it
and okay open that gate that gate there
you know that one down there we need
that open what if that side in
corporation is winning what if that that
group is winning and beat out the group
that want to say exclusives see here's
the thing that's side of the corporation
is the reason the Xbox has to drop on
almost everything they pick up after
time like I said mixer what else they
didn't they make
Zoom like the hand little music thing oh
Zoom Z okay got you Windows
phone what happened to Windows Phone
well then just don't try nothing right
that's what you say just
don't my point is is we already trying
something we already in this market what
you saying
okay my point to that is just because
the higher ups think something I just
gave you multiple scenarios where they
thought something there too and it
didn't work out all right so hold line
hold line it's a k man there a lot of
lot of soft talk that I know you a
appreciate but uh we had to talk about
it this is the rumors that's going on
right now you know high five Rush
potentially one of those games that
could be rumored to Nintendo switch or
other platforms so uh how are we feeling
about
this are you
Cadets here we go all you Cadets I want
you to take a long hard look at these
mustard harded chicken chested
individuals with the Jelly back spines
and I want you to never walk they walk
because all I hear is fear in their
hearts it's
real I'm scar now now now we do have a
little couple of Nations that we're cool
with Nations all right and we are cool
The Sovereign Nation of Nintendo we are
cool with the Nintendo Nation they don't
they don't tread on our we don't tread
on their land and we do happen to have a
lot of things that we want to do so we
giving them military armaments we have
been if you have looked banjo kazui is
over there right now in Smash
Brothers if you have looked ay is over
there right now so individuals is making
a bunch of hoop over nothing
oh now that mother dud them snitches
those rats oh man them
backstabbers those individuals that are
soft to the car those liars and
deceivers you won't get anything
here you'll get popey
biscuits the same thing that we've been
giving you an absolute fist full of
nothing uh-huh you can take that one to
the bank there take that to the bank now
Nintendo we like the way they move over
there that she she look cute
she but that's not holding the lot is
it CU we definitely want some of that
market we definitely want to slide our
game pass up in they
situation so win game pass is running
rip shot over there when we uh you know
put that little Trojan Horse up up in in
there and we get them to over there to
play over there and have some fun with
our stuff uh that's what we're looking
for but listen high five Rush
definitely you dudes ain't playing it
you dudes ain't buying it it's in Game
Pass right now yes you're having fun
with it right all right all right so
let's put it over there for that $70 let
those guys get over there let them have
fun with that over there on that new
Switch that's gonna
launch cuz they they was the first ones
in line to sign that Call of Duty
contract so why not reward the
indivual down with you all right so so
now what what what about what's next
Nintendo in court did Nintendo point us
out no so why y'all got a problem with
little old
Nintendo High Rush shows up on
PlayStation though but them PlayStation
dudes if highi Rush shows up on
PlayStation what if Godzilla comes in
and Stomps your house down right now we
do what all day it ain't going to
happen it ain't going to happen uhhuh
so let's all stop with the fear mangarin
fear mongar and all this chicken chess
talk but King you have to General you
have to admit that if one of these
weapons keep going over Nintendo one of
our best weapons goes over Nintendo fun
with it what's the the precedent that it
says that that now maybe every XBox
exclusive we got to ask you General is
that going on
nintend going to Nintendo's new system
run is a vow going to nend system we
know what they can run and what they
can't run okay okay we gave we gave them
atomic bomb that they can handle yeah
they cannot run a lot of things they can
run certain things metrics over there
and they able to do high five Rush let
them Rush on the high five we want to be
in on the launch too okay
so that's right we want when you turn on
that little old Nintendo switch we
wanted to say Xbox Studios oh okay and
we want y'all to say wow this game was
fun I wonder where I can get some more
that oh give them a taste than the
sequel and the DLC over on okay see get
them high on your supply let him get a
taste give them some and when they want
part two you know where you got to
go all right so this so just to be clear
as as a reward we trying to get them
hooked as a reward for their loyalty
during the Great War of ABK the peace
treaty was signed with Nintendo and th
this and this was a reward this how we
rewarding our mutual Ally in combat see
this is how you this is how you you know
here you go sir thank you for showing up
because the deals was made hand Shanks
was done hand you ain't going to snitch
on us right because Nintendo could have
came in and throw a monkey wrench in the
whole situation that is true that is
true Nintendo said Lo we don't got no
problem with those dudes they great with
us facts they did say that they did they
held the line they they Advanced the
line for y and they signed first and
they show their signature we signed with
them yes they capitulated you are
correct they did capitulate well then
let let let us use Mario Zelda in
our that Slater don't get all greedy you
get greedy you scared her away don't try
to scare her away man don't scare away
don't scare away now now I want you I
want you to know this because a lot of
you chicken heart dudes little mustle
chest guys you got this stuff going on
over here I want you to know this
Nintendo could have royally screwed this
true you right and Nintendo St so why
not give her a high five why not she
need a little high five in the Life
y'all two together are gonna kill
Kong both and you ain't gonna kill Kong
by yourself oh you think you going to
kill that grade eight by yourself that's
not going to happen you got to make sure
they climb the Empire State Building
then you send Nintendo to shoot them
down and then while you down there you
kick them while they falling you got to
make sure that they don't make it it's
going to take a two-prong effort okay
okay so this is one of our we in war
this one of our best allies we rewarding
them for a successful Mission and then
now we combine the the the switch to
give them that okay cool nooke all right
Blood In Blood Out Blood In Blood Out
and all that people you ain't about
snitching and when the dude don't snitch
you don't reward him I feel that I feel
okay okay get high on high fire Rush go
ahead man have a little taste have a
little and then once we get your hook
you know where to come check us out at
come get the DLC come get part two got
to come yeah you know where you got to
come all right all right right down the
street like like a Motel 6 we keep g a
sold I don't think G Gast is sold but G
gas I I I wouldn't mind look I don't
care that much highi rush and the switch
actually thematically goes quite well
that's okay but we need a clear
messaging because what we don't want the
Stables to run with is like well when is
our turn and it's like there is never
your turn so Microsoft messaging is the
key uh problem here tell them it's their
turn when they get
ay uh well it's never their turn it
should never be their turn when Matt
boot is saying we can outspend them out
of business you spent $70 billion you've
done this what it really shows is a lack
of faith in your own brand to be
sustainable on OWN on its own back that
you have to go ahead irrespec of the
good faith showed by Nintendo or steam
or whatever in signing this contract
during ABK the Xbox has a unique uh pos
position now ABK is it's like like
Smooth was saying you've just done the
deal you've got ABK through an
incredible process and then you just
didn't even try to actually do it on on
your own back tell the truth and Shane
the devil gas your only true concern is
Sony right yeah absolutely okay then so
this is why I call people
mustart we have not shown to be going
across the street over there messing
with those dudes we have not shown to be
we have not no no it's only speculation
from them dudes cuz all they like to do
is put out deception and lies
they want you to believe that they gonna
get something they never do get it they
wanted you to believe that they were
sustainable that they was making money
they wanted you to believe that that
retched and Clint could be only done on
the SSD they wanted you to believe a
whole lot of things but we come to find
out that they are nothing but lies
cheats and charlatans so now don't fall
for the banana and the tailpipe pause I
want you to understand they will not get
anything and I don't care who writes it
up or who sums it up or who drums it up
Nintendo will get cuz Nintendo in the
YSL case M they did not snitch you
understand no gunning situation they
they didn't snitch on young slime you
got G Park laughing in the CH all right
so we know who snitched and who's a rat
and who we not messing with they will
never Nintendo was 10 toes down in that
that's right Nintendo they kept it g
they kept it g you got to say they are
they are Italians so they kept it a buck
theyt go to the like no we don't do that
over
here said said hey Luigi get away from
that
degenerate don't hey hey hey Yoshi don't
you drink out of that cup over there
that degenerate over there that Sony
let's go back up up our stuff we're
going with Microsoft I can't with you
look I'll jump in real quick um look I
I'm not going to believe anything just
yet until I see we get an official
Source cuz we are speculating in in
King's defense we are speculating it
thank you but the sources are you know
pretty
reputable Nintendo I mean you know highi
looks like it's definitely going to
Nintendo and that's not the problem hii
is the outlier because it like all
that's like two I I don't care
PlayStation just do not deserve you
cannot you're battling them you cannot
have it and the messaging behind that
from Phil Spencer
needs to be clear why it's happening how
this is going to go what other games are
going to come on platform what is the
you brand it you call it something like
absolutely no the sad part about it is
this this is what I know one thing for
sure and two things for certain I know
everybody in that building is pissed off
at Sony for what they did with
ABK
everybody from from from from SAA
telling you yeah if you want competition
then let us do this bro yeah let us
really swing let us really swing at you
right and and the fact of the matter is
M booty over there telling you we'll
spend you out of business these are the
people that's in charge these are the
decision
makers I don't know not one of those
decision makers that's going to say yo
let's reward this stupidity of these
dudes over here with anything right
because there's nothing over there we
found out that they don't buy games no I
get I get dudes buy games no I get where
you at and I listen from a financial
standpoint it makes sense I get it it
would sell like hot cakes over there I
know it will my issue is kind of what
what G says because Phil has been on
record for saying when they asked him
about why was aie over there right yeah
his message was like now we look back at
it that may have been a mistake we we
create this Narrative of what whether or
not an XBox exclusive should or
shouldn't and he said he didn't agree
with that so if the high five Rush RBA
is true it is kind of double speak we
got to be real and I love at the end of
the day we so you got to be clear to
your base on what it is because now what
happens is every single XBox exclusive
that comes out is going to have a
question mark on it yeah going Nintendo
is it going over there is it going over
there when Nintendo get it yeah we have
to be clear this is where Microsoft's
messaging is terrible I am sorry I hate
that about be conclusive and stand on it
stop we we can't have this every time an
exclusive comes out will it will it it
true I mean but it's the same thing with
steam I mean steam was 10 toes down to
and said yo you know um the fact of the
matter is we don't need a contract with
these guys it's just rewarding those
people that are standing with you so say
it so don't don't say say he can't say
that you can't say that you can't say
but you said but you said or you said
aie on there that wasn't the move
somebody pull the quote up say yeah of
yeah you you can't say because
Nintendo's still with us on the trial we
gonna give him this game you
Phil the current position contradicts or
it it is an indication that Phil Spencer
failed to do what he said when he said
in 2020 I don't really love this idea
that for every one of our games there
comes this little rumor is right now
that it's going to end up on the switch
or not I feel we should set a better
expectation with our fans here right now
true that was that
preab yeah it was 2020 2020 so preab
right it doesn't change the no it
changes it changes a lot of things if
you in a if you in a fire fight and a
dude that comes over and lays down the
gunshots for you and get you up out of
there and be like yo don't worry about
it we good money I ain't G to say
nothing let me get rid of this for you
handle your business man get home safe
get home safe my guy and you look over
need to speak to the Troops and say yo
look these no no no no don't tell that
don't say that don't say that why we
can't say that you can't say that in the
street because then then that then then
that's collusion bro that's not
collusion you just got to give a
handshake and a wink my guy and high
five shows up so then so then he can't
nobody can't get mad when we say well
what's up with hellblade that's coming
over there what's up with a V that's
going over there whatever so again they
they put themselves in this position if
this rumor is true the game ain't there
yet though yeah that's true we we again
in speculation that's the game a there
yet but the smoke is there yeah but the
smoke smoke is say but remember when
they were shooting at you who had your
back no I say that all right so you got
to and if yo think about it bro like
what you saying right now is so if I if
I get in that firefight and I watch you
getting beat down I run over there and I
just bust shots and I get you out of
there you ain't going to look out for me
you a't going to look out for me I am
not I'm not against Nintendo I'm saying
I've got your back but the the general
that's making those handshakes also
needs to speak to the Troops and say yo
this is what we're doing and this is
where how so you want Phil to come out
and say yo since Nintendo held us down
in the ABK we going to slide why you put
words in my mouth I'm
just I'm just saying like speak Nintendo
was 10 down yo he us to speak to us and
said this is what we're doing oh so you
want him to send out the Illuminati
email so you can just get it you I'll be
happy with
that that's all I got other than that
let me read the quote that Phil sent me
um yo Nintendo held us down and we got
to slide him a little something what do
you think King ah send him all send him
high five Rush that's what's
up listen at the end of the day I I
understand if now we're GNA have people
saying Phil spok K exactly look if it
some old be honest you that's what I
thought I I even though it's not
confirmed I'm like all right if it was
like Psychonauts to right you know um
see of Thieves because you're like all
right laugh service needs to exist maybe
everyone else will get more Revenue okay
fine Oblivion remaster Fallout remaster
all right it existed on other platforms
before whatever whatever I think that's
I think the emotionality is that I think
kid and and gas said high five was kind
of like their first one yeah which was
you know what I'm saying a critically
Acclaim game you know beautifully
designed the whole bit and then it's
like people are like damn like cuz even
you got to admit King you're the first
one when kajima is up on stage we got
your boo we got your B you know what
saying we got one of yours you know what
I'm saying so that's what we going to be
like and it sets this thing the only but
that game ain't coming out for them
though it sets this thing where people
sit is is it a uh Playstation thing we
don't know or is it no this is what I'm
saying y'all okay is it a PlayStation
thing right or is it a Nintendo thing
because we all believe the Nintendo
ain't in this
fight I think is yeah that's true but
look at them as high Rush is the only
game really that would work there
hellblade 2 is going to be streamed it w
work there right there we go exactly
like what else like most of Xbox's Games
should not be able to even work on a
switch even the next gen switch if it's
just high- five rush it makes sense cuz
it's such a good game more people should
should experience that but that's on
Nintendo except PlayStation you guys
made fun of that right that part that's
okay that's okay but it needs to be
backed by clear messaging even if it
happening looks like it's happening I
don't care about it but so you want
Microsoft to come out and say yo we'll
never mess with those dudes but we're
really mess with them guys no no he just
want to say this is in for this game for
high-f fire rush we felt like we needed
to bring Nintendo's a lot of synergy
with this game but in terms of like then
we understand that there have been
questions around about exclusivity and
the position Remains the Same we will
only go on games where platforms where
Game Pass exists this one isn't an
outlier because we felt like this is a
unique opportunity and we have a good
partnership and I love Nintendo blah
blah blah blah that say that it's not
hard to say and just do that there's no
harm in saying that that what if okay
what if to your point right what if to
your point that new Switch has a
accurated Game Pass something on it then
Xbox say is won majorly because Game
Pass has got market share under the
handheld Market in a way that mobile you
have to look at the switch as mobile
game passes like the Trojan Horse bro
this is the B coming in now they've
invited third party in there it's going
to be a Cloud solution or whatever
that's going to make it run Xbox has got
a major win Revenue up oh so then you
down for that if game pass on the switch
and that's everything though see see
this is where streaming that's a
streaming solution right still
everything it's still everything but
it's not the crem deem like streaming is
still streaming like you're still that
the Ultimate Experience needs to be on
the Xbox console or perhaps PC see this
is why I give a little bit of push back
now because if they do have game pass
over there that you know Game Pass is
part of the function of it is to be able
to download set games so let's say some
games is able to be downloaded and oh
let's say
Halo Halo downloaded locally I'm just
saying well I'm just saying on the
switch plan
anyway well it's still I don't know man
Nintendo's it's weird like ideally I
don't want any of it but I don't think
you were just telling me this is a
massive wind
breath it doesn't bother me like I mean
if it's if you think about it switch so
it doesn't bother you right if it's Game
Pass like it's backed on Game Pass
that's a massive major win PlayStation's
going to be worried think about what's
happening there Xbox has increased its
Revenue massively PlayStation's looking
to die at that at that stage I don't
think Nintendo would allow it crazy but
I'm just saying like I'm just What If
part the What If part was if they would
put Game Pass there you'll be okay with
game pass on it but you're
not the Ally does that already yeah what
difference does it make to me that just
these dudes because I'm saying this high
five rush I don't care if it's over
there it's going to sell you get him
hooked and you know high five rush to
come over here yeah but you're open to
Game Pass going over there yeah Game
Pass going to play
you
open that mean the moment Game Pass goes
to PlayStation PlayStation is dead you
have to understand that it's just it's
just not workable with the third party
IPS and whatnot just logistically not
possible unless Microsoft says we let
our first party stable only on Game
Pass then kill it then that just cannot
happen but if Game Pass in his current
guys and the full breath appears on
PlayStation PlayStation has conceded
that's the point PlayStation will be
dead before even the ps6 if's no way
that happen no see what I'm laughing at
is the hypocrisy in it is that high five
rush just one game yeah just going over
there to reward loyalty yeah that's okay
okay I don't have a problem with it we
just want them to be clear about what
they doing I think I think whenever the
game if the game ever goes right
whatever happens I believe they will be
very clear in whatever the message is
like this this game is over there
because the Synergy between Microsoft
and Nintendo is at this point and X Y
and Z I ever I don't ever believe that
it's going to PlayStation at all in any
form I believe the animosity in that
building is so high and is at such a
point that they want death for that
other team they will never come out and
say it but I honestly believe they want
them to become an app honestly but
Nintendo they have an A affinity for
Nintendo and I think for some reason we
all do we all feeling that Nintendo can
do do no wrong and we have no problem
with stuff going over the Nintendo we
like that's okay but I was just wanted
to see if you would allow everything to
go over there opposed to just being
upset with the one title me personally I
let the one title
go I I think that's less feasable it
could happen but it's so farfetched to
me that that that would happen if it
does happen though Microsoft has got
massive Boon that I see the switch as
like a rug Ally you can have every game
pass game there it's like what's the
difference like it's feel I feel the
same way that's why I didn't feel way
when I heard this stuff at all I know
for a fact it's not going over the
PlayStation but it's just PlayStation
dudes we may get it n shut up you won't
that's that's all I care about man don't
just and be clear with the messaging and
like double down on it if you do high
five rush like an outlier who cares
that's actually probably good let them
play jdub can finally admit he likes
high five
r